إن سلامة هواتفنا المحمولة ضارة ،
حيث تقول لجنة الاتصالات الفيدرالية التي
تضع إرشادات لمقدار الإشعاع الذي
يمكن أن ينبعث منه الهاتف الخلوي ، إن الهواتف آمنة
ولكن البعض الآخر ليسوا متأكدين من
أن منظمة الصحة العالمية قد
اتخذت خطوة استدعاء الهواتف المحمولة
مادة مسرطنة محتملة وهي مادة مسرطنة.
العوامل المسببة للسرطان التي تضعهم
في نفس فئة مخاطر الإصابة بالسرطان مثل
الطلاء المحتوي على الرصاص وعوادم الديزل ، فكيف
يؤثر إشعاع الهاتف المحمول علينا
وما سيستخدمه الكثير من العلماء
لوصفه ويقولون
إنه يتسبب نوعًا ما في ارتفاع درجة الحرارة
يشبه إلى حد كبير بيضة على سبيل
المثال يتم طهيها
وقد تكون أدمغة الأطفال أكثر ضعفًا ، حيث
تكون جماجمهم أكثر نحافة ، لذا عندما تتحدث
عن الإشعاع يكون من الأسهل
المرور من خلالها نظرًا لأن
أدلة سلامة الهاتف المحمول ذات الجماجم الرفيعة تخبرنا في الواقع
أن نحافظ عليها  الهاتف على بعد حوالي نصف بوصة
إلى بوصة من الرأس ، إليك
الأخبار السارة ، من السهل جدًا تقليل
تعرضك أبدًا للتحدث مع الهاتف.
مباشرة على رأسك ، استخدم
سماعة أذن ، لذلك أستخدم دائمًا قطعة
مثل هذه ، إنها سلكية فقط ، أجد
أن هذا هو أكثر الأشياء أمانًا ولا
تضع الهاتف مباشرة على جسمك ،
كما أنني لا أضع الهاتف في جيبي  في
جيبي الأمامي لأنني هولي فيفرير قريب
جدًا من الجسم مرة أخرى في الدقيقة الصحية لليوم